[Music]
thank you
well hello once again dear friends
Welcome to our program I'd like to know
a question and answer program where you
send us your questions and we do the
research and do everything possible to
answer your question
um I want to give you the email address
where you can send your questions to us
we would be delighted to receive many of
them we receive more in Spanish than in
English so I'm hoping that many of you
who watch the program in English will be
sending your questions you'll see on the
screen the email address it's TV at some
tv.org once again TV at some
tv.org we would be delighted to get your
questions by the way I'm Stephen Bohr
president and Speaker of Secrets
unsealed and I have with me
Pastor Salazar David Salazar who is the
newest addition to Secrets unsealed
we're delighted to have him along with
his wife and his two beautiful daughters
and thank you for being here for the
program and God bless you thank you
Pastor it's a blessing to be in this
program and sharing with you this time
together here and answering questions
and we want to have a word of prayer
absolutely should always pray before we
open the word absolutely could you pray
for us please absolutely let's pray
Heavenly Father we thank you once again
Lord for allowing us to come together
and willingly we want to ask that you
will help us to understand your word
help us to share from your word what the
answers to the questions that our
friends are sending and we ask the Holy
Spirit maybe really our guide our
teacher and the inspiration to the
answer is that it may give joy and
direction to those that are asking and
seeking the truth we pay all these in
Jesus name amen amen amen okay what's
our first question for today Pastor Bohr
we have this question and a friend is
sending the question about something he
saw in church I'll read the question for
you it says I will startled this past
Sabbath as I walked in the door for
services last week the Usher gave me a
ticket with a number on it and she said
here's your ticket to win some of the
gifts that are that were on the table in
the foyer they even call the number out
during Divine worship service I was
bothered by this and just needing to
know what the Bible and inspiration has
to say about the issues of Raffles
especially during Divine worship thank
you in advance for answering these
questions
well
um you know the Bible does not directly
address this specifically
and I would have some additional
questions to ask the person who sent in
the question uh by the way it's Frankie
Owens who sent in the questions
um
it's very common I have found for
example in evangelism right to have
certain gifts available
and there's not enough gifts to give to
everybody and so basically they have the
visitors register and they give them a
ticket and then they have these gifts
and they announce a number and the
visitor comes up and picks up one of the
gifts right that's done during
evangelism I don't see anything
particularly wrong with that
um you know
it's not gambling because you're not
investing any money right it's not a
raffle really that you're paying a
ticket yeah you're not paying for the
ticket now if you had to pay for the
ticket I would have a problem with that
because that would be kind of like
bartering kind of like uh luck you know
who's lucky and who isn't lucky right
but when it comes to giving away gifts
uh I don't particularly see any problem
as long as it doesn't disrupt the
reverence of the worship service you
know if it becomes like a Marketplace
300 200 150 you know something like like
somebody who does an auction that would
be a problem but you know if it's before
the sermon uh and you're welcoming the
visitors uh to uh you know to give away
some books or to pamphlets I don't see
any problem with that no pastor and I
think you are absolutely right we I know
in the church I Pastor that and during
evangelism the past we had to do these
things where you will give as mentioned
a gift you can buy for everybody but at
least you could be able to give them one
of them you know who had a ticket or
something like that but it's it's
commonly done and if it's done as you
mentioned without disrupting the
reverence of the church without bringing
in some sort of a fribility to the to
the to the concept of getting the gift I
think that's not a problem but if we go
into raffling you know like real Raffles
or bazaars or something like that as or
Bingo or Bingo or something like that
absolutely wrong and and we have you
know as Professor mentions and clearly
states that such a practice is wrong and
should not be in the church it might be
a good idea to read yeah those
statements um and it's not dealing
specifically with this question but I
think it would be good to read what
would not be allowable in the sight of
God in terms of Raffles and bazaars and
you know sales and things like that
absolutely I read from pamphlet 48 page
16 it says we are not to imitate the
churches and speaking of the Fallen
churches by instituting basars and
various God forbidden experience
to bring in a little means we see no
direction in the world for fancy fairs
concerts and other object novel
practices for raising funds to advance
his work the curse of God is upon all
this kind of work
it is polluting and degrading to the
work of God defiling his holy Temple so
we see here that you know Raffles or
bazaars or or some sort of way to raise
funds
that are made to create some sort of
idea of a I guess a game or something
like that is is really a curse of God I
mean is is is the filing that his Temple
so it's polluting as he mentions and
degrading it's kind of like uh you know
when I was growing up
in Latin America
uh it was very common there to do
um you know to make tamales or to make
arepas you know which says yes make food
and then have people come and purchase
the food and then they would use the
funds for the church budget or whatever
and that would be questionable right
because you know if you are willing to
give the money to get an arepa why not
simply give the money without the nap
you know you're really bartering you're
getting something yeah for for a price
right for buying and selling and uh God
loves the cheerful Giver absolutely
where you're not getting anything
exactly you're giving right right right
I think Pastor that's very clear and
hopefully this question Frankie can take
the principles and if again if the
church is
doing this you know buying or some sort
of making the person buy tickets or that
kind of thing that would be a different
story but if it's just not uh that
experience if it's just a way to give a
visitor a gift of the many or you know
or the few visitors select one I think
it's not a problem necessarily because
we don't see it going against principles
um all right so let's go to the next
question Pastor you want me to read that
for you yeah please okay
so let's see here these are very
interesting question a friend from uh
Ghana uh tells us this question says
hello I'm Emmanuel from Ghana I really
enjoy your program we are thankful that
he enjoys the program amen may the Lord
God bless you all for being a vessel for
him my question is that was Jesus
treated like any other kid in Nazareth
uh and then maybe having some fun
getting into some trouble parents
training and advising him on what to do
and what not to do
so I guess this is an interesting
question from Emmanuel about Jesus yeah
that's interesting yeah
um what Pastor you tell us what comes to
your mind about
this answer to these questions well one
thing I can say for sure
and that is that Jesus never got into
trouble
uh I think the you know we don't know a
lot about his childhood up to the time
that he was 12. you know and uh and at
12 we know that he went to the temple
for the first time after that till the
age of 30 yeah we don't have any
information other than what we find in
the Gospel of Luke right and I think you
might have those verses right Pastor
Luke 2 40. uh it basically says the a
beautiful verse that says and the child
grew and works strong in spirit filled
with wisdom and the grace of God was
upon him
okay so um there's no mention there of
specifics just general principles that
he grew right a physically mentally and
spiritually one thing I can assure you
and that is that Jesus never followed
his friends in getting into trouble
right because we are told in the book of
Hebrews chapter 4 and verse 14
um actually verse 15 for we do not have
a high priest who cannot sympathize with
our weaknesses
but was in all points tempted as we are
yet without sin Jesus did get into
trouble but because he was faithful to
his father not because his friends led
him you know astray absolutely and so we
can be sure but Ellen White does mention
some things absolutely about the
childhood of Jesus uh maybe you could
read some of those quotations correct
and we find these in this set of Ages
and I will encourage
um our friend Emmanuel to to read the
whole chapter but it says the following
What's the title of the chapter the
chapter is called the the childhood of
Jesus or or as a child I actually have
not the title of the chapter but is Page
71 and on
um and it's a chapter just for the
chapter of Jesus and he speaks of this
way she says the life of Jesus was alive
in harmony with God while he was a child
he thought and spoke as a child but no
trace of sin marred the image of God
within him
yet he was not exempt from temptation
the inhabitants of Nazareth were
proverbial for their wickedness the law
estimate in which they were generally
health is shown by Nathaniel's question
can there any good thing come out of
Nazareth so Jesus was placed where his
character will be tested it was
necessary for him to be constantly on
guard in order to preserve his Purity he
was subject to all the conflicts which
we have to meet that he might be an
example to us in childhood Youth and
manhood so
it was you know he was tempted as you
mentioned there he had to be constantly
in guard so that he will not fall into
to these Temptations are not to fall
into sin but he in in no way he marked
his character his life by sinning so the
fact that he never
you said it clearly he could not have
got into trouble for doing the wrong
thing it's a testament to the way that
he was raised by his mother you know his
mother raised him in the fear of God and
he was strong in Grace and also I will
say that the only time he got into
trouble that we see is when he stayed
behind at 12 years old or you know he
was sort of age but what not because he
actually disobeyed his parents
necessarily they neglected him he was
doing the work of God in being a temple
so there is no way that Jesus was you
know uh marred with with sin when he was
a young man and and I definitely he was
not able to travel or being a nuisance
to society yeah and it's interesting he
was obedient to his parents
and when he went to Jerusalem when he
was 12 years old
and he went to the temple and he was
asking questions of the religious
leaders yes and the religious leaders of
course were trying to give in give
answers and then Jesus would would talk
back to them right
um
you know he was unconscious that his
parents had left and when his father his
father said to him don't you know that
we've been looking for you for for three
days now uh Jesus kind of rebuked Joseph
and said I need it to be about my
father's business so it was kind of a
rebuke saying you know even when it
comes to parents yes God obeying God
trumps obedience to parents incredible
what a blessing and you're right Pastor
that that shows you the type of cry that
Jesus the way that Jesus was another
thing that I would like to add another
quote from the spirit prophecy just to
make it very clear you know there's a
reason also that Christ was able to stay
I guess without falling to Temptation
and she mentions as a child I mean she
mentions the following in page 72 of
This Heart Of Ages the parents of Jesus
were poor and depended upon their daily
toil
he was familiar with poverty sadly Nile
and privation this experience was a
safeguard to him in his industrious life
there was no idle moments to invite
Temptation so the fact that he was
needed to you know as a child work and
today people would say that's child
labor child exploitation but at the same
time you know because his family was
poor he had no idle time to be you know
getting to travel or having some fun
that will lead him to travel he had to
help his family have to work how to
provide us he could so he says no
aimless hours open the way for corrupt
corrupting associations
so far as possible he closed the door to
the temper neither gain or pleasure
Applause nor sensor censor could induce
him to consent to a wrong act he was
wise to discern evil and strong to
resist it so the experience it very
clear that he did not fall into
temptation he did not you know go into
trouble he did not follow Bad Company as
you mentioned
Christ was able to keep himself pure and
sinless by following the Lord and as you
mentioned God above even above his
parents and Ellen White mentions that he
was very meticulous as he worked in the
carpenter shop with his father oh yes
yes that's absolutely true he was very
particular in doing the best at the
world possible yeah and uh yeah and work
kept him out of Mischief exactly which a
lot of children today need to do I mean
not necessarily make them work but they
should be active in doing something
productive you know yeah I can't imagine
Jesus constantly texting on his phone uh
you know when there are far more
important things to edify your mind
absolutely and to Spirit your spiritual
nature absolutely and I think parents
need to have as the Lord for wisdom
Pastor you know to be able to to train
them in in in really allowing them to
develop the christ-like character even
from a young age yeah so all right okay
very good uh let's go to the next
question this is this is a question that
I have never heard asked before
this is sent by
Adon niram
da cunha
uh probably from Brazil or one of the
portuguese-speaking countries
um why do some still correlate the great
city of Revelation 8 8 11 8 with France
when if we are Christians who really use
the Bible to interpret itself the
context lends itself to be interpreted
as Babylon every other mention of the
great City in Revelation and then he
puts uh Revelation 14 8 16 19 17 1810
refers to Babylon
additionally Daniel 4 28-30 also
mentions Babylon as the great City
I can see why there has been a decision
to think of the great City in Revelation
11 as France due to atheism unbelief
Egypt Exodus 5 2 and lawlessness Sodom
at Genesis 19. however this argument
Falls flat in the face of Greater
scriptural scrutiny Jerusalem is
mentioned as Sodom and Gomorrah for that
matter Isaiah 1 and Egypt Jeremiah 9
because of their apostasy and Rebellion
wickedness idolatry vain offerings evil
assemblies appointed feasts fornication
thefts and Injustice
um there are all these are all crimes
attributed to Babylon throughout
Revelation as well not necessarily
France as they never fail into apostasy
so basically the gist of the question is
why do we understand the great City in
Revelation 11 verse 8. uh why have we
said that that relates to France
whereas in the rest of Revelation the
expression the great City refers to
Babylon and I think the answer to this
question is
in the sequence that we have in the
chapter right
um
the sequence of the chapter makes it
very clear
that we understand Babylon to be the
papacy of course the Harlot of
Revelation chapter 17. when we go to
Revelation chapter 11 we find first of
all
that
um there's a period of 42 months
and then it says that when the two
witnesses during the 1260 days or 42
months right
has come to an end correct then is when
this power called the Great city rises
uh let's go and Factor Revelation
chapter 11. yes and see that
you'll notice in in verse 6.
uh speaking about the two witnesses the
Old and New Testament these have power
to shut heaven so that no rain falls in
the days of their prophecy and they have
power over the waters to turn them to
blood and to strike the Earth with all
plagues as often as they desire and a
little earlier it says in verse 3 and I
will give power to my two witnesses and
they will prophesy
1260 days clothed in sackcloth correct
and then when you get to verse 7 it says
when they finish their testimony
at the end of the 1260 years right
the Beast that ascends out of the
bottomless pit
that can't be the same power that ruled
1260 years no the Beast that rises from
the Bible is another Beast will make war
against them overcome them and kill them
and then you have in verse 8 uh called
Sodom in Egypt right so clearly there's
a distinction between the power that
ruled 1260 years which is called Babylon
correct the Harlot or the Beast and the
Beast that rises from the abyss which is
called Sodom and Egypt so when you see
the sequence of powers correct you see
that the great City not only applies to
Babylon but the expression applies
elsewhere
and absolutely pastor and also just to
you know com confirm what you're saying
it mentions there in verse 11.
that after three days and a half the
spirit of life from God entered into
them and they stood up on their feet
which with great fear fell upon them
which saw them so it was uh even though
they were killed
the scriptures will be to put it away
for a certain period was not gonna be
forever and it really cannot fit with
any other power in history than the
power that Rose as a as a beast of the
balance pit which is that Southern and
Egypt which is the French
system which was the revolution really
the French Revolution that really came
about and destroyed all sort of moral
and put away all you know atheism all
took away the Bible and this and that's
holy word so that's yeah and and you
know uh the in the question he seems to
indicate
only
uh
Babylon is the great city right however
there's a place in the Book of Jonah
it says arise go to Nineveh that great
City and cry out against it right so in
the Bible
terminology
can vary according to the context right
so
Asylum can be called great City
Babylon can be called great City
France can be called great City
Nineveh can be called great City in
other words
symbols and terminology not always refer
to the same entity right there it can it
can vary you know like Lion for example
what does a lion represent in the Bible
[Music]
Satan right the kingdom of Babylon Judah
the son of Jacob you know you have to
take into account the context the
sequence of Revelation 11 clearly
indicates that this is another power
that rises after the 1260 years to war
against the Old and New Testament right
which testified in sackcloth during the
1260 years absolutely and at the end of
the time when they were resurrected it
will bring even more there will no
longer be included in Cyclone you know
they will actually be expanding the
great lighter great uh reform not reform
but the Great Awakening happened right
when they went after this experience of
of them being destroyed by Brands so
also I think that is important that our
friend who brought this question
understands that certain powers are not
mentioned until they are relevant to the
uh the you know the sequence of events
so you know the fact that maybe
he's not seen friends repeated in the
future doesn't mean that is not
important for us to understand what how
the prophecy was laid out so that's
important yes yeah okay the next
question
um we can probably answer in the four
minutes that we have left okay well it
has to do with the Ten Commandments you
want to read the question yes I have
three questions in one practice all
right so this is from Andrew O'Neill and
the question is was the first set of Ten
Commandments made of sapphire stone and
taken under God's feet therefore blue
that is found in Exodus 24 9-12
and it was if it was made out of
sapphire how could the table break
Sapphire is the world's second strongest
gem and with sapphire under God's Own
feet breaks so easily could the Lord
have broken instead of the Fall against
The Rock against I'm sorry could could
the Lord have broken it instead of the
Fall against a rock or the mountain
and are the second set of Commandments
made out of sapphire like the first set
or possibly just a blue stone it doesn't
seem possible for Moses to carve
Sapphire so would have to be a normal
Stone
that's the question so it's interesting
questions regards to the Ten
Commandments and the tables what they
were made of
um Pastor what did you take on this well
let me just make a correction here
the last part of the third question yeah
it doesn't seem possible for Moses to
carve sapphire stone the bottom line is
that Moses did not write the second
tables of the law they were written by
God himself according to Exodus chapter
34. right but you know I have heard the
idea that the Ten Commandments were
written on sapphire stone you have to do
a roundabout analysis of different
verses and put them together to come to
that conclusion
but I don't see any proof in the Bible
that the Ten Commandments were were
actually made out of sapphire stone I
don't know if you have a different view
but not really yeah I've heard the
theory right but as I've studied the
evidence I'm not fully and completely
persuaded right it's it's kind of lapic
I guess an interpretation maybe but not
really a real or is an application more
so than the interpretation of the verses
I think is very important not to be too
dogmatic about that or to to say you
know certainty because it's really not
not enough proof to really like I said
persuade us to say yes this is the truth
um the fact is that uh there is that
that concept or that idea going around
but I don't think we can embrace it as
it's not really clear you know from the
spirit prophecy or the Bible about that
you know it's possible and uh you know
it's not a matter of Salvation we'll
know when we get to the kingdom right
but some people say well you know there
was a border around the bottom of the
Garment of the of the Israelites you
know which was blue which represents
God's Commandments yeah uh so you know
you might uh connect that and say well
you know the Ten Commandments were
written on blue stone sapphire stone but
uh you know there's a lot of conjecture
involved uh I think the important thing
is not uh the stone that the
Commandments were written on but rather
the Commandments themselves absolutely
and the fact that they know that he that
they were broken when Moses
threw them to the Rock I mean it could
be that the Lord allowed that to happen
you know as a sign of how they broke the
the their com their you know their
Covenant but it's it's really hard to
pinpoint or know or give you an answer
that really makes sense so yeah well our
time is flying away we want to thank you
for being with us for this program I'd
like to know please send us your
questions TV at some tv.org we will be
glad to do the research and answer them
in so far as possible God bless see you
next time
[Music]
thank you